welcome to your mom's house
so we are waiting in line to get on the
tram and we saw a little 20 year old
girls and it's funny because yeah there
and it was a cold day in LA yeah that's
where a sweater or a jacket it was cold
and people don't understand I think that
live in other parts of the country that
it does get you know brisk yeah on
certain days you know it'll be you might
be used to it if you live in a really
cold city but it gets to the point where
people wear jackets well especially when
we were in the in the mountains there
the wind blows it's cold as fuck but
there's always young girls shivering in
LA whores are always cold no matter what
whores get cold because it's more
important to them for you to know that
they're whores there's a warm yeah yeah
and they're a dress like whores yeah and
only white the Getty you got a dress but
I guess maybe the Mapplethorpe exhibit
they wouldn't go see dicks but yeah I
don't know I don't think those girls
were looking for those ya know what were
they looking for it I don't know but
they definitely were they're shivering
little chickens in line I put in work to
be a whore yeah yeah that's a universal
truth man whores are always cold always
cold yeah especially I remember when I
did Indianapolis I did a crackers in
broad broad ripple once when winter and
it's that's a legit cold and it's yo oh
yeah and it's in that bar area where all
the kids are yeah and I just a stack a
horse around the corner and it's snowing
outside crazy it is not a joke you see
it any if you go Friday Saturday out in
any city yeah you'll always see those
cold hookers walking around and the
heels you gotta wear hit your hooker
heels and you got to be cold and
shipwrights
airports yeah you see chicks wearing
like eight-inch stiletto that's a fly
right yeah in the morning I now the
morning flight and you appreciate the
effort you're like a hard-working hooker
but you don't have to do this for a
fight no get comfortable yeah get
comfortable bitch yeah in a tight Club
in the yeah you're wearing this to to
sit yeah to sit uncomfortably on this
flight so fuckin weird and you'll and
it's still fucking early
we went you don't look like this till
tonight right yeah I don't know unless
she's sucking it at the airport you know
suck at the airport
giving a little suck suck